[Music]
welcome to the vc panel this is always
my favorite to organize because I'm a
crazy founder I love pain I'll founders
have to look pain I don't know if you do
that but when we started three companies
and turned one into a conference you've
definitely been through some pain in
your life but it's great to have you
guys here and I'm happy but the company
turned it to because this really um so I
typically try and find the most
technical investors I can because like I
wanna I want someone to talk to me 15
years ago when I started my first
company when I was a code writing
engineer you didn't know anything about
sales didn't know anything about
marketing he didn't really know anything
about building product but I thought I
did and I just always heard have been
passionate about helping other engineers
over those roadblocks because I know
there's a lot of us that wants our
companies and we just don't know where
to start so I'm really pleased to
introduce the panelists these are some
of the most technical investors I could
find and they're very technical Jonathan
was previously a blog cloud which is
market research company then he was VP
infrastructure at Facebook Leo was
formerly an engineer at Microsoft
LinkedIn Google and factual it's all
right
Leisha has found data science at
interesting companies statistics and
where else interest and she have a PhD
in staffs from early and they're all
investors now so really happy to have
them here and thanks for joining us so
we'll take some time for questions at
the end so it's think thinking about
those and stewing those a bit I just
wanted to ask you guys first to kick
things off as technical people when did
you first think that you might want to
be an investor how did that happen
what's the story
anyone I don't believe the paddles in
order by the way it's where it's gonna
fix a nightly so for me it was
accidental
I actually I was at two startups when
there were three small so I was a little
kind of in the 50/50 first range and
everything like that phase and after our
told at last there was anything funny
but I felt like didn't know and
basically I got lucky my friends of
starting a secon and they were looking
for a partner and so I thought I'd try
it for a year and learn a little bit
about like startups and investing from
the side of the table and I think
throughout the process realized they
really liked that shirt so I lost count
of how many sort of spins in the washing
machine of figuring out I want to be an
investor or entrepreneur gone through
but the first one was I sold my first
company I started to Global Crossing and
in 1999 for those of you alive them was
either a horrible time or a great time
to be in technology and for us actually
pretty good time for big telco very well
capitalized lots of fiber lots of
customers but we really haven't had a
brass when we came to technology as
let's telco still do and we're
constantly being approached by VCS and
startups to hey you know put XYZ in your
lab but XYZ in your network etc etc and
so I turn that around I go to his room
age paper presented it to the CEO CFO
the board and said we should really dig
a hundred million dollars off our
balance sheet and invest in companies
and to perform our own thesis things we
think are interesting and products we
could help shape that could
differentiate us from our competitors at
the time
level three quest ATT sprint etc we did
that we invested about forty fifty
million dollars from the beginning of
ninety nine at the end
and for expat money but I was like 22 or
23 and I didn't really like being an
investor at that point until I left and
joined mob cloud which became all square
at its inception and then did a bunch of
other operating things much much later a
couple years ago started Metro firm
again now at this time I think it stays
for me it was definitely quite a jump
from an academia so and even my path to
academia was very much like I wanted to
be a professor I went to Berkeley and
ending up doing mathematics but also
chose Berkeley because I thought well
very else has a ton of interesting stuff
going on so if I ever distracted at
least the things I could distract the
area extremely exciting so a couple of
things happened I tried some internships
in data science found the product
oriented kind of roles where you have
data drive decisions where you have what
the infrastructure that actually allow
data to inform decisions in a clean and
and a high quality manner very
interesting I also like the cadence of
industry so interact with a bunch of
these C's from there because you know
these seasons invested these pre-ipo
startups Pinterest stitch makes it etc
and just kind of had more of an idea of
what investing and because it seemed
very black box me and on top of that I
think just throughout my entire both
academic career and somewhat dubbing to
this day at the time I solved for
interesting people ideas and in in that
sense that was the underlying activity
that really connected to venture
guess you don't get to write research
papers or a delve into a particular
topic but with that said as a
technically focused early stage investor
you're very much focused on finding
excellent people who are doing very
interesting stuff and if you enjoy that
activity it's it's the same thing you
get to do as an investor as I was as a
constituent so so what do you think is
required for an engineer to be great
what what is it that you look for when
you're talking to the time
person and there's some Watership moment
where you sort of have an Indian that
this is a person that's investable look
what does that look like I mean I do
world it's someone who's experienced
pain in their life he talked about the
pain necessary to being a founder having
had some of that pain because if you
think because the pain often leads to
solutions leads to creativity you have
whether you're a big company or a little
company you saw some problem weak
investment enterprise it said that that
tends to be our pattern and you saw some
problem you decided to do something
about it quite frankly I think that
that's one of the next kind of thing is
well what are you gonna do after the
first act so what's like the big vision
of the company house is going to make a
dent in the world or make a real
difference house it will change by
virtue of the product of the company
existing that the engineer a technical
person wants to have and then I think
the third element again ideal world is
someone who's actually had experience
selling stuff before it's something I
did not do early on in my career and
learn the very very very hard way that
building products and selling products
are two very different things
and actually going out talking to
customers asking for the check you're
getting the order delivery in the order
supporting it that's that's super super
important as well yeah I completely
agree with Jonathan there for especially
given a lot of amplifies portfolio you
know centers on people who've lived
through the pain points problems and
then ideally they have people in
training also being able to sell the
product as well they go with that set
for our portfolio we also focus on a lot
of machine intelligence apply to
verticals and in these areas sometimes
the research that's going on is so at
the frontier that you actually can't
find people with that level vector2
expertise so we start with meet academia
you just can't satisfy those up to other
things and so at that point what are we
going to kind of look at you can just
and a PhD student right or at least
that's not our foreign policy so in this
case you look for people who are willing
to go to customers even if they not you
know apply to something say in very old
industry like manufacturing logistics or
not go find some use at 20 years
experience there and also knows deep
reinforcement learning but if they're
willing to talk to the customer so that
they're not just have they don't just
have a technology want it just find a
sexy problem but are actually engaging
with what are the pain points how do i
spec out this product then then we're
going to fight to fund those teams and
as suiting of us we should just have to
take a risk there a couple of things
I've seen the pinch which is basically
selling to investors I have to recruit
and I think a lot of this stuff they
actually have to do is like this an
engineer you know but not as much under
the popular because you can do it all
over there's not you have to do so I
think people like to do that really well
that's a really quality I think the
other thing to kind of related to that
is seeing the founder role as being more
than just engineering sitting this is
actually like crispy to say as an
engineer cuz I always want like the code
and the soccer team a most important
thing and I think actually most products
are buildable what was really hard to
decide it's like what products should
you build it or like you know who she'd
be marketing to or how you market it I
think what I've seen own engineering
teams those you know myself too and I
think about snart project ideas I think
about the technology won't be cool to
build come on follow the LEAs languages
I think there's also a big difference
between solo founder one person and a
team of people coming together and often
it's the sort of the tapestry of the
team that makes it really interesting
and it could be people with
complementary skills it could be two PhD
grad students that worked in the same
lab but having to have a dialogue with
the founders about one what are this
kind of what are your strengths
weaknesses where do you want to
compliment the team or if it's so you
know the first solo person who's the
second person or third person they bring
on and just to have that dialogue I
think you me the founder is he's very
very illuminating both for the founder
and for the investor kind of what comes
next
yeah so sales sales Hills Hills was
mentioned sorry guys we get to that
point quickly on these types of
discussions and I was a solo founder we
didn't really know anything about sales
tool to a product I thought was cool and
you know had lots of issues like
probably imagine at the end of that
company was um how do you sort of
spoon-feed an engineer who wants to sort
of get over the sales hump like hot you
how do you like change the mindset
because it's a really tough thing that
we're all as engineers I think sort of
read to be averse to sales marketing
like this out to be beaten out of us or
is there some more elegant way that you
can sort of coaches through and out so I
think it's it's hard to convince
somebody it's important if they don't
think it's important I think what I've
seen is that as people do think it's
important that they're not reversed art
or maybe they think it's important but
they're also really confident they can
do it and they've never done it before
it's like sometimes the right person
other times they're not that good but
they think they're good things like that
could be problems so I think for me and
a lot of us understanding like how does
the person abuse sales does it have to
convince that it's important in which
case I'll be just as a don't go or is it
more like you know they want to be good
at it but they don't know
how to do good which meeting an advisor
or like meeting some great salespeople
and try to understand like what they do
it happy to do it yeah I think someone
told me once that when you're an early
stage company everyone everyone who's on
your [ __ ] table as part of the team so
what I discovered through starting
several companies is if you don't have
the skills that you think you need and
maybe you don't even have a co-founder
who has the skills you think you need
surround yourself with other people set
up an advisory board as early as you can
give people small amounts of equity and
put them in your deck like use them to
inspire to use and to encourage you use
develop you build a sales pipeline you
can you can attract and find those
people and tack them on to your company
as it were even if you don't have the
capital to hire them and that was been
super helpful to me you like it's the
community it's sort of my belief in
community right like that's why I get
the conference together because I really
believe we cannot help each other and
God knows have asked all my MBA friends
15 years ago to join me in a saturday
morning in my office to help me
brainstorm this product that I wanted to
build and they were my first buzz reward
and that was super super helpful to me
I'm supposed to stone octa deities so
back to the another angle of the sales
you mentioned sort of how the VC has to
perceive the business Jonathan so one
thing I see with a lot of startups is
they have their current product and
their sort of current go to market idea
but then there's this tightrope you walk
between sort of extending out the vision
of that company so it looks big enough
for the investor and sometimes there's a
tension between what your product can do
now and what you really wanted to do and
there's
tendency to kind of create some
pie-in-the-sky panacea on the vision
part like any any advice as to how to
walk through that as a bounder because
out so in particular tension I see with
lots of companies that are trying to
paint a really big picture but they
maybe just have the edge of the wedge
now so I think two points there firstly
we we just spent the last five minutes
talking about how great and important
salespeople are don't overlook engineers
some of the other engineers we've all
been sold to buy maybe the MB a sales
person who's not a founder and not a
head of product but there's something
very special and authentic about having
an engineer to engineer conversation
that can then turn into a hey I really
do have this problem in inter like you
said like to your question on yeah I'm
figuring that out it's actually
interesting over the last four days and
obviously in a variety of those
configurations with different founders I
think one of the riskiest that's I think
headline be honest the authentic don't
lie because you know so it all comes out
in reference checking and diligence and
talking to customers and it's a very
real situation when the rehab situation
a guy who had raised a seed round it was
getting too shocked very very
aggressively to raise a Series A spend
some time with one of my colleagues came
in that everyone and we sort of left
that meeting scratching our head of all
right this guy's clearly very smart he's
built interesting business he's hired
extremely well with all the people in
the company but everyone is a talent
amazingly talented he booked not
collected a couple million dollars in
revenue but we also walked out of the
meeting scratching our head trying to
figure out exactly what the value
proposition I was promised and over the
course of a couple more days he sort of
looked back to us and my colleagues
needs to go what I told you I was doing
on Monday oh that's garbage I threw that
all away I've literally taken a
90-degree turn of my product now and
that obviously doesn't sit well with an
investor
under recycles so that's probably bad
behavior much more positive example to
give use media I just came from those
two founders they have to be repeat
founders so there may be a little bit
older and I've kind of seen a lot of
false pathways to go down in development
but they had acquired Ivy on the
university setting along with Roth and
lead investigator I guess or grad
student working on it
joining the company and their the vision
they were pitching was exactly what he
described agenda but here's the product
here and now we don't know where it's
going to go and then I turn that around
to say well like what's your process
what's your journey look like how are
you going to figure out one of the
things want to test but what are you
curious about and then we just had this
free-flowing half an hour conversation
that didn't lead to any conclusions but
it Illustrated to me that they were open
they were willing to take feedback from
customers they had already talked to
customers who weren't paying them
anything and that they were like they
knew that they didn't know the answers
but they wanted to get them and so that
obviously I think that much more
positive and uplifting feeling about
this would group the people who I really
want to work with and who I think could
build something interesting even though
they don't know what it is yet so it
might be that you know maybe to make an
analogy like you might be trying to
marathon so I think if your plan is like
Wellman or you know walk a hundred feet
today and I'll figure out you get to a
marathon like let's not agree but you
know if you're like I'm gonna do on your
feet today and 150 next week and then
you know like 58 weeks I think I'll be
there I think that's a lot you know then
it can sort of figure out like I think
make sense and I think it just shows me
a thoughtfulness and I think also if
you're pitching to investors they'll
drilling on the things that there start
to call about you know so they might say
like oh you're gonna jump from like 10
miles a week to like 15 you know three
months are you gonna do that I got that
sure you can do that and then if
probably ask you about it that means you
if you think about it because you know
maybe there are going to be we need to
you know have a little bit more detail
there and I think through that process
you sort of develop this map that you
know today I'm doing X but in seven
years it's gonna be a lot bigger and
here's like what possible okay um let's
take it a little bit more specific to
data because I want to hear from each of
you how your thesis for yourself or your
funds investing how that maps or or
doesn't map to data or sort of what's
your perspective on on data as it fits
into your investing thesis it's
certainly very important I'm trying to
think of a good frame framework for this
so kiss for amplified Enterprise focus
either infrastructure security or
machine intelligence
so really pertains I guess all three
pillars of our focus areas it's
certainly true that having a data boat
or an asset that allows you to tackle
particular area is important and I think
what kind of excites me when I talk to
the cars it's not necessarily rich in
say AI forex or you know whatever 4x but
like how how do you it might not even be
automated right now but how do you get
to a a way to collect through the
workflow that you're kind of making
easier and how you're pushing the
product so that you're actually
collecting really interesting to you
that nobody else has so I think this
actually gets into some areas like how
do you compete with the behemoths of
Amazon and Google etc why name one way
is to tackle problem that might be too
small or uninteresting for them but if
you actually want to go head on in and
maybe tackle problem that Amazon might
want to solve or Google might want to
solve it's like trying to do the
groundwork where you're understanding
the need from the customer and and and
really sucking out something where right
now it's not it it's not a product where
you're using mission
telogen sodomy but you're collecting the
right work process process see policies
so that eventually you can on that super
exciting so I see that in both maybe
computational crepe so view or logistics
just the the solution right now it's not
necessarily the automated one but
creating a really easy to use tools that
you get that yeah I think we really
focus on companies where if they're
doing something are machine learning
the key thing to look for is that they
have kind of a route to an interesting
proprietary data set I think almost no
company I've ever seen is doing like
cutting-edge Michigan learning
especially not in the early days and
usually like usually whatever their
advantage comes strong and strong you
know they have some kind of data source
that nobody else has where they're
fighting multiple data sources that
nobody else can combine and then that
combined with like pretty standard but
wall to and learning algorithms so I
think data is important there I said it
but what you do with it and the business
that you can build around it to your to
Leo's point is actually way more
important as a fund data is it's one of
my partner's it is my partner's cohesive
he started era he helps our Couchbase he
really likes data and GPR in compliance
and this is sort of slightly I'm talking
to them one of the things I think you'll
find when you talk to investors or has
you as you're talking this was think
about starting a company is some
investors are very thesis oriented and
particularly like you want to talk about
data they'll talk to you all day long
and gaming and doodles those areas
topics
personally I'm not a thesis driven
investor but people driven investor and
therefore my portfolio looks a lot more
like a dilettante since I haven't you
know I like sort of a lot of different
things and kind of best day computer
vision
team team-building vision algorithms
that we think are interesting and unique
and the data set that they build on the
back with that is is equally interesting
but I also invested in a 3d metal
printer that has nothing to do with
machine learning and that's just who I
am as a as an investor versus um do you
think there's a difference to acquiring
a data stack generating a dataset
because of your product success I think
of sort of the obvious examples of
Facebook and Twitter they just sort of
generate more UGC data constantly it
seems like you know those are now today
those are the best examples perhaps of
some of the largest businesses that
could be powered by Google powered by
data that we know even though they
didn't start up as such do you think the
next generation of data businesses will
be built the same way and that it's the
it's the the opportunity of their
success that generates the data or are
we talking about spelunking for data and
finding new forms of data that are not
online yet in radiology scans or other
places in medical or documents that
haven't been OCR or like do you have any
perspective on those two options and
sort of where the future might a curious
about that
so so so I think the kinds of tools that
we talked about where don't sound like
the word clothes pillows to children
horse we're getting some kind of I think
that's how I've seen a lot of companies
build basically their their data moats I
think if you if you go like spelunking
your data but that's a good way to get
your initial data set but if somebody
else can get that they decide you know
it's not going to be a sustainable
advantage that you know so I think you
know even if you start out with my
parting something or you know sharing
them with somebody or something like
that you still have to figure out in the
long run I'm like well how do you go
beyond that and add something all the
pulse of yarn which might be you know
proprietary data said it might be a
network effects might be something else
but it can't be just the data that you
require - I completely agree with that
and just to kind of give it more color
by delving - an example also very people
to run in Buster's so sometimes I double
that computational like biology
startups and they're you know you really
have to partner would say a pharma
company that can give you some data if
you're saying we're trying to solve for
a drug discovery but every company that
starts there can also say hey I can use
deploying or a very big mystical the
techniques for this so what's more
exciting is can you build an automated
lock what word you concede it with the
data by these partnerships initially but
this platform is what gives you the kind
of experimental apparatus to do a
high-throughput experimentation and then
you can actually solve the second
complexity problem of getting enough
data so you can generate interesting
ideas as yourself so it doesn't example
where you you know it's not a consumer
products you're kind of building
something where the more data that you
collect them the better you are to some
synthesize more proprietary ones and
that you really generate a motor for
yourself yeah I think the biggest
business is in recent
times have been businesses that have
generated new datasets or where users
activity the exhausted users activity of
Facebook Twitter etc or Google generates
new data sites that doesn't mean that
taking existing data mining and
harnessing it mashing it up with other
data isn't a good business it just means
it's not a five hundred billion dollar
business but it might also be a
fantastic hedge fund look at how most
hedge funds are constructed that's a lot
of what they do is they take interesting
interesting datasets can apply human
intuition and how goes to to mine it and
come up with their own conclusions and
trained on those complete so will you
invest in any company that has a thought
AI domain obsession but this actually
goes to the point I want to raise which
Leah you mentioned we probably share a
similar view in that there's a lot of
startups out there that just don't have
enough data to science I mean how how
can you in almost every case any more
specific advice there to give to
founders who you know they're thinking
about hiring a data scientist or there
may be considering too early any sort of
common patterns you see there where some
things they have a data oriented
business and the way they talk about it
but in reality they just need to see a
successful product fraction to perhaps
start to generate meaningful data as as
we mentioned which is just though the
the basically success of a business and
the traction of the product just curious
if you have any general comments there
about the wayfinders pitch you suppose
the data data oriented data
opportunities
sorry to have about how founders [ __ ]
data oriented opportunities versus the
science their data yeah I'm just
wondering question if I wasn't worded
particularly well but I'm wondering if
there's any common pitfalls you see and
the mentality of a founder as they
approach what they consider to be a data
oriented opportunity yeah so I think
it's exactly as you described there's
oftentimes not enough data to science
and regression analysis or Excel
modeling can do amazing things
large data sets personally I really like
the sort of tactical like here's the
here's sort of the problem here's my
analysis like here's the value we
deliver for customer that we could build
for a customer versus going deep on the
science before there's really enough
data to to warrant it it might be the
most amazing beautiful Ferrari Eska
machine but you know the Honda actually
goes down the road and gets things done
a lot faster yeah I mean just I think
points that we've all hit on which is if
you're if you are really kind of
thinking through your end customer use
case and then designing the products of
abilities it and they'll generate the
data that's that's right one report
there's even if they might have a great
pedigree and are technically very
skilled but can't just build a shiny
tool and expect people to use it so so
did that plain distraction from all
track traction speaks volumes
acceleration velocity really speaks
volumes yeah I mean I guess we also have
s you know pre product for attraction
free any kind of data in terms of
traction and there it's really just like
are you willing to
talk to customers this day so if you
haven't even done that like work and to
take a good feedback from investors and
those customers to spec on the product
then it's a wuss but if you take enough
first stuff that we're willing to work
with you in infancy yeah that's a
scenario that were interested cool um so
I also want to ask some infrastructure
questions who's investing in data
infrastructure and why or why not
it seems like a pretty crowded market
right now sorry so I'm really investing
in data infrastructure and I might be
much time I've got the majority of this
panel but my personal experience as an
engineer is like I rarely saw tools that
were for a cutting edge and like the
best tool you can used for you know ten
years in a row can see something that
was great for like two three five years
and their place by the next thing I
think the next thing I think is an
investor really looking for companies
where we think they'll be dominant like
you know six eight ten years maybe feel
public someday and so I find that
dynamic convener for search companies
where they're often getting replaced by
like the next version to be really hard
to manage the Buster have you made any
infrastructure investments over the
years or is this a newer newer started
in your personal business
we've done a little bit I think we saw
our funds about you know five years old
so we did a little bit ten the first two
- here's something we've done a lot less
than anyone else we made a number of
kind of data infrastructure and
analytics and particular investments
three years ago when we started the fund
we invested Zemel which is five Zeppelin
project Thank You Pere David look and
Atanas very high in Linux - Leo's point
many of these products are generational
and kind of truly and get replaced every
couple of years where there are big
markets
that business intelligence is a
reasonably big market it's actually
forget how big it is but it's in this
with tens of billions of dollars of
software spent plus services then that's
a suitably big enough market to make
investments where the company may not go
public but the outcome will still be
sizeable for the founders time and for
our client as well in terms of in fact
an infrastructure propping it is
extremely crowded I think basically free
wins and then figuring out where you can
build a value-added product in charge
maybe a prize customer or something
that's not an early adopter building
everything themselves is getting to a
thinner and thinner
and so that's why we've started shying
away from quite frankly infrastructure
as a whole cloud cloud in for data tools
etc is largely for that reason I would
say that's similar to amplifies of you
we have been keeping our eyes have been
on the infrastructure for yes water
machine intelligence one so in that now
from what's interesting is that you also
have put the hardware stack that you
want to think through and it's not just
like you know chips that are optimized
for Ivan if you have like a system
solution that have the correct
abstraction so that you could think
ahead of or not let your Hardware
constrain the kind of models that you
can run so it a very holistic approach I
do is companies were still very
interested in so just a quick a
counterpoint to that I'm not saying that
everyone should go out start data
infrastructure companies and from a
macro perspective it may or may not be a
great investment or as good of an option
with other other options other sectors
from an engineer's perspective you know
the YC
model mandate is sort of build something
that you need yourself because a it's
really easy to figure out the pain it's
much easier to sell especially if you're
an engineer
and you don't like selling anyway and
it's just it's easier to be passionate
about so I think that's a counterpoint
like investors to think in terms of huge
markets and where they can take risks
which I again but not every engineer can
afford to think like an investor and not
every company you start is going to be a
billion dollar or even a hundred million
dollar exit so in my experience have
spent a lot easier as a founder just to
like just to build what I'm passionate
about my care about you have to make
sure you can sell it and I solve
someone's real need but I wouldn't over
look at that that really is for the
basic core ethos of what you care about
because it really matters
and it keeps you going through the long
haul even what you think things are
going wrong I want to open it up for
some questions yeah please Robert here
thanks so much for the taking all these
questions especially fascinating so far
I have a question about the kind of data
mode strategy so I've heard this analogy
that when you have PII you can think of
it metaphorically as hazardous waste
you know if it's to be handled very
carefully it would kind of like to
minimize how much I've ever had in
bigger picture there's this issue of the
ethics of data collection data analysis
and I'm curious what are your thoughts
on should companies can strain
themselves and what they collect and
what analyses they produce concretely to
the sea stage company make sure to try
to deep is there word embeddings as
early as they can you know things
like are there are these things that
you're thinking about or you're
encouraging people in your portfolio to
think about I'm sorry we mostly work
with b2b companies so I think like you
know holding consumer data doesn't imply
the most of them my general feeling is I
think it is a personal decision link so
definitely don't do anything illegal and
then I think if you think something is
shady or you know have your company
doing something today you don't do that
either it's not illegal beyond that it's
really hard to draw a line you know
because even like demographic data right
like let's say you find out that people
over 40 or twice as likely to find what
they're for deeply should you not use
that or is that like is it okay - maybe
like spend marketing dollars I'd like
some demographic I think it's really
hard to draw a line of like know like
what is okay what is not
similarly we only focus on enterprise so
there's less of an issue of collecting
consumer data I mean with health data I
think there might be something to that
you have to be careful abide by HIPAA
cetera of maybe like taking a slightly
related tangent is like for
opportunities and then embrace startups
taking sort of trying to provide a
solution for authenticity and addressing
bias the data might be a really good
direction to approach I mean I I know
that for instance this is catching up
for some folks and and Facebook are
leading their more to AI ethics that
they're really looking for startups in
those area to to help inform a lot of
their problems
yes so you guys talked a lot about how
important it is yeah like experience
talking to customers and working with
those customer facing teams and really
like sales experience when you're
starting a company so for a data analyst
or a data scientist
how would you cultivate those
experiences if it's not really your
day-to-day what your day is like looking
at the data running models how do you
like get that experience well I mean I
think if you could start with community
appears for example if you have if
you're working collaboratively on
projects of the people at other
companies treat them like customers and
use that use them to validate ideas with
these
I think that's Pete made the point
earlier than anyone on your cap table
even before they're out there on your
cap table to be treated as employee so
if you're talking to potential
co-founders or employees or investors
they should be providing potential
customer intros and and/or references
it's a two-way street of course but it's
an opportunity to figure things out and
then I think some of the greediest
founders that we spend time with are
unabashedly even as engineers cold
calling people on LinkedIn saying hey I
think I think you might have this
problem or I'd like to talk to you about
this problem and I you know buy a cup of
coffee or Scotch to talk about it I
think the other strategies to try to
cover your customers are so I you know
if the state engineers maybe go to
conferences like this one right or if
it's consumers maybe you go to Starbucks
and just offer people like five dollar
gift cards or a free coffee if they talk
to you for some minutes so I think
there's that aspect to it just like
wherever people hang out that you want
to target like huh speaking trying to
try to go to those places
one way I got over I learned more about
sales the founder was - recruiting when
I was recruiting engineers from my team
I discovered that it's really easy to
find any engineer you need on LinkedIn
and you basically had to build a list of
100 of them you know he mailed them all
get 20 responses back in the age of ten
me five of coffee
hopefully hire one so when you think
about the numbers like that I would say
you know do the same run the same game
with your product because it's really
easy it's not hard to discover the 100
or 200 people in the world that you want
to talk to you can find them all on
LinkedIn especially if you're selling an
engineering tool for the most part I
think it's just about really getting
serious about building that list and and
figuring out you know the cold outreach
thing I think it's just gonna super key
in my career I sort of got me over some
of my fear of sale I didn't even think I
was selling I just thought well I need
to talk to hundred engineers to get one
to drop and so you just have to do that
numbers game I mean the authentic intro
specificity if you get rid of this
reminded me why Combinator but they're
also saying that you know if you're
solving a problem for somebody they'll
be excited to talk to you
alright so if you're building a tool for
somebody and you think they're their
customer and you fish on the tool like
they'll be happy to talk to you about it
and give you feedback but I tell you
what other things I can say yeah so it's
not something there's a problem
so going back to the data storage and
sort of the assets of a company I'm
curious what your thoughts are between
data proprietary data and IP and patents
what's what's more valuable to a
start-up so I'm may be overly biased
here I don't think that's worth anything
unless you're executing they're great
for defense purposes when you're in
medium or large company but until then
go build something that's all the profit
find the problem solve the problem make
the customer happy so to that end I tend
to buy us towards the the teams and the
people who are taking action in whatever
form that takes that could be their own
data processing that they don't want
them to writing insights actually a lot
of experience with patents equipment my
feeling is that meat is more valuable I
think I'm feeling Facebook I'm sure they
have a lot of paths but I bet of all of
their hands became public in my keynote
public that means Dave I don't think we
really fact anything for them but I
think a third a toe is something that's
always like Google and Twitter and like
startups I think that would be very
different story
when you fund companies do you estimate
that this would be a small workforce
what would you look for me in three
years down the line this is going to be
X amount of dollars do you put a dollar
amount if you start funding the company
or just the amount of people this would
actually affect those kind of social
support well you know in combination
trying to solve her next round in
finance Amy which is more so long at all
to 18 months and then also like what can
this company potentially become what are
the exact same options I think for
enterprise there's a lot of just you
said go public that there's acquisition
targets etc but I think it's solving for
revenue like those are tangible things
that you can aim for me but yeah
building product that people use and
eventually pay for that's what's going
to trap the next round of money I'm
saying and at least shown subtraction
towards achieving those goals yeah I
would say we do a fair amount of
introspection the good news is it's
mostly wrong it always generally under
day degrees opposite direction you know
something that we're conservative on
palms and it's amazing it's something
we're optimistic about it's a falling by
the wayside for some reason that we
could see at the time but we do spend
time for example in data and data bases
and we probably see a new database
company or data storage engine idea
every other week
none will be Oracle and that's the
unfortunate reality of that industry and
so what I mean by that is that the
opportunity and the promise of for
example the selling of that product for
ten million dollars to the business as
Oracle does and as I say he does is kind
of over but so then we think about like
okay well what would this business be if
think it's all for $50,000 or $100,000
and is that an interesting business and
are they able to acquire can we imagine
a world where they could acquire
customers that that becomes a profitable
endeavor and doing some of that math I'm
not talking about building out a
spreadsheet or modeling like that
especially at the seed stage at subject
but to at least kind of go through that
might be exercise the pendulum exercise
then what will this become and what
fundamentals is that based upon so the
thing I'd add is for most EC funds the
way to get a successful fund is you have
an outlier to it so if you less than 30
companies the good funds don't have you
know 20 of those companies like pro 5x
that one company that grows like 200 X
and then that returns like the whole
time five times over and so I think what
we look for in each investment is do we
think there's at least sunshine you know
it's like half a percent or something
but this could be one of those companies
that returns the whole time for a chance
it's are all times over so I think
that's the main thing that we use is
like a full prod
and I think a lot of things that some
from that are things like job creation
you know you don't get to be that size
unless you're producing value for it
like the rest of the world and then I
think we all mean my partner's all have
our own personal filter is a point does
this actually make the world a better
place and I think those send a married
person or persons like some people think
that is really boring and you don't need
to know their outside company others
think that's great because it like
enables all these other great companies
free so I think those kind of things are
more personal using intuition and maybe
sometimes data how much of what you do
do you think
so there's a fun that thinks you can
automate much about all of that even at
very early stages I think it's very very
hard to do that simply because for the
point of view made then trophyless work
because of outliers by March most
businesses fail butts these are the
unfortunate reality of businesses
whether it's a restaurant a bar or a
tech startup and the variability there I
think is too high I think also we're
doing a lot of work trying to match both
teams together so even like perhaps for
later stage you have the data to collect
and the right signals at labels they can
create a model like maybe they'll be
helpful because at that point you
already have two companies that exist
like Target metric zero for cetera but
for the early stage you're really I mean
this
fun that you're really trying to bring
teams together and help them seek out
what what customers have talked to you
and you know do this matchmaking job and
that's kind of hard process to automate
to look at our crystal ball gazing and
matchmaking as you said and then I think
the journey changes it probably changes
maybe quarterly maybe monthly maybe
twice a year depending on the company
because the DNA of the company changes
that that the markets changing all
around you and one of the things I think
that's hard for people who have been
operators and in turn our investors is
not just across that bright line of
interference with a company because
we're never as good as we think we are
it's it's all about you guys the famil
there's the operators that are actually
doing the work but you know the
perspective we have is is one that's
just longer range and where we can
sample data from across the portfolio or
even our friends portfolios to hear
about how things are not working in a
particular market but then it's beholdin
of us to indicate that data for you know
the valve or the founders to to use that
to make decisions in their own
messengers
I'm sorry on that topic when you think
about like a Series A or a serious
beating the quality of diligence packet
I'm just sort of curious about we're
talking about big data mostly me right
and companies that do specialize in we
did a hedge or get a service but in
general are there any particular metrics
that stand out I've just seen diligence
packages get so much more sophisticated
so much earlier I'm curious if like on
the evaluation side of it a sales funnel
of a year and a half of data as well yet
or not or if you have any thoughts there
so I do think it's valuable you know I
think even a company that's been selling
for six months has an interesting data
in their sales fall you can speak to
velocity you could speak to conversion
rate lead source is it affiliated
revenue meaning I'm Sonya buddies is it
on affiliate in revenue and actually I
have cold calling discovering customers
our customers coming to me is our an
organic or managed to acquire those
leads all only those types of things and
then I think similarly especially if
it's a service and a data service the
cost to run the service is an
interesting question you know by the
time companies are raising series B most
serious B investors are looking for a
seventy percent Chris margin or greater
in addition to a business that's it's
ripping and hopefully growing as fast as
possible and so if the company might be
in forty percent gross margin that the
time the racing series days what's your
plan get to 60 or 70 or 80 percent Chris
merging two or three years from now so I
think they do think there's a host of
questions that that come up somewhere
very standard and some might be more
specialized based on the product and
service things
yeah I was just gonna say I think
investor is like even a little bit of
data is better than no data so even if
it's just three months that's so useful
I think even from that you can pick up
signals so for example I think for a lot
of companies like the series a growth
rate might be something 15% monthly so
if you're like 8% even if you just talk
about it like two months of beta I can
sort of say well you help me generate a
series day off of this unless you got a
way to accelerate it you know the
flipside if you're keeping like thirty
percent for three or four months even
though it's three or four months or it
gets excited because my father's are so
far above average and I think especially
especially interesting it's like metrics
that are hard to gain so like the time
that people spend you know your tool
every day for example I think that was
one of the things that's no it's like
this people are using it like eight nine
hours a day like you can kind of think
growth because if you put more money
into marketing and sales it might not be
very affordable but like you can get
more users for something to engage our
attention when those numbers are good
people get really excited
you